three months ago Rainbow six seeds was
on top of the world the 2020
Invitational was gigantic more people
were playing the game than ever help we
made a whole don't at me about how Great
Siege was but now pro players are
leaving content creators don't want to
play the game and there's negative post
after negative post all over reddit so
what the hell happened
[Music]
why are you surrounded by instant
noodles
man it is literally all-out the eating
since shelter-in-place started there is
no way I'm going aside right now look
man
even with everything going on Bravo biz
still delivering your favorite food
right to your front door right but is it
actually safe yeah man it's really safe
and with contact free delivery it's
never been easier to get the food you
actually want while limiting the spread
of coded and supporting local
restaurants the food gets dropped off
right at your door safely you don't need
to break any of your social distancing
guidelines thank God I don't know if I
could do another bowl of instant noodles
how much instant ramen have you eaten it
is the only thing I have eaten in a
month alright so right now siege is in a
bad spot and how we got here is really
complicated so to help everything make
sense
I've broken down this issue into three
specific categories cheating the new LAN
League and the meta obviously there's a
lot to discuss within each but these
three problems seem to be what most
people are upset about so let's start
with arguably sieges biggest problem
cheating if you've paid attention to
siege at all in the last five years you
know the game has a giant cheating
problem we've covered this topic a lot
and don't at me before but the problem
seems to be worse than ever right now
I'm pretty sure that is DDoS the server
you have your typical stuff the wall
hacks the aimbot errs the stream sniping
all happening on official Ubisoft
servers now other FPSs have a cheating
problem I mean just look at csgo but the
big difference that separates csgo from
siege our external servers with csgo you
have third-party options to play on like
face it or ESEA which both offer robust
anti-cheating systems something siege
lacks face it for example has an
intrusive anti cheat program on top of
that you have to pay to plan the premium
servers while also stating who you are
which deters a lot of cheaters all of
this leads to servers that are generally
better and siege has none of that the
only way to play ranked siege is on
Ubisoft's official servers which has a
weaker anti cheat system and results in
frozen lobbies frequent disconnects and
DDoS attacks the whole thing while
cheating happens at almost every ranked
level it seems to get worse the higher
you go to the point where pro players
and talented content creators competing
and diamond and champion ranks are
having trouble playing the game and it's
this rampant cheating that's caused
up-and-coming pro player mode digger to
leave the game entirely when I first
started siege I could actually play like
10 to 12 hours a day I could stream all
day I could play and now I can't because
half the games are cheaters alongside
cheats dependent on third party software
is something like stream sniping which
heavily affects streamers and content
creators and has casters like in taro
asking for some sort of streaming mode
to help fix the problem the siege
community has even made mock-ups of what
this streamer mode would look like but
Ubisoft has been pretty quiet as to
whether or not they're gonna include
something like that you know you have a
cheating problem when somebody like
Maisie J who is the biggest are six
siege fan out there contemplating not
playing the game anymore because
cheating is such a big issue on top of
all the cheating there's the
extraordinary amount of bugs that are
plaguing the game and while you Basava
does patch them out each patch seems to
create new bugs now it's not like
Ubisoft isn't trying in fact they're
trying like hell to get this cheating
problem under control they've banned
thousands of accounts but battle I the
third-party anti cheat software that you
basalt uses doesn't seem extensive
enough to really make a dent in this
problem why do I have to use
well it would be because Rainbow six as
a anti-cheat that does not work at all
whatsoever
well everyone is talking about how
cheating is making si Jin nightmare the
next topic I want to cover is this new
version of pro-league that Ubisoft is
talking about so pro league season 11
finished on April 13th and it was the
end of a competitive siege as we
currently know it taking na pro league
spot is a LAN league that's reportedly
going to be based out of Las Vegas and a
big reason we know about this LAN league
is because former luminosity gaming
siege player hyena recently released a
twit longer about it that set the
community on fire now the controversy
behind the LAN League in the hyenas
tweet is extremely complicated and if
you want to know the full story we made
a whole don't at me breaking it down
basically what you need to know here is
is that negotiations between Ubisoft
and multiple are succeeds organizations
about their involvement in this new land
league broke down and because of that
those orgs released their rosters and
now former pros who competed in season
11 of pro league don't have teams last
time I talked about this situation I
focused on the luminosity gaming roster
who were dropped from the org after LG
backed out of this new version of pro
league this time I spoke with members of
Evil Geniuses
another org that released its roster
after similar negotiations with Ubisoft
fell through the EG players that I spoke
to feel like they've had their pro
league spot unfairly stripped away and
because eg won't be competing in this
new land league the pro league spot that
the roster feels like they earned is now
going to another team but we've had that
spot for like five four four and a half
five years we've been in relegations
before we've made it out of allocations
we've won pro league season so we're
fine with competing for it and if it
happens it happens
we got relegated then we would've got
relegated but to not have a chance to
compete for your spot that you have
pretty much sacrificed everything for I
mean it's pretty frustrating now
according to the players the reason why
eg won't be participating is because it
doesn't make sense for the org
financially one of the examples i've
been given is the fact that EG is based
in washington and would have to move to
Vegas and apparently find new housing
for staff and players they came talk to
us and we're just like that this is
what's going on we don't agree
like we don't want to make that move
it's not like smart for us and babe we
went a different way they went their
separate ways and people don't know who
to blame fingers are being pointed at
uvas off for lack of communication
others think that LG and eg should have
done more it's a mess that allegedly
forced Ubisoft to make a statement about
the LAN League earlier than planned this
is eg we're talking about there is au g
as it gets when it comes to competitive
siege
it's like fnatic suddenly dropping out
of csgo after competing for the last
decade now we still don't know a ton
about this new league and I'm curious as
to what specifically has so many orgs
either pulling out of siege eSports
entirely or deciding not to get involved
at all okay so that's everything we know
about the LAN League the last issue I
want to talk about is the game itself
right now the meta is not in a good
place and people are pissed the simplest
way I can explain this after talking to
a few players is that basically siege
has become incredibly utility dependent
making it a chore to play and boring to
watch attackers have to worry about
valkyrie cams Goyle shields and echo
drums and then there's bandit batteries
to deal with goo mines and up to eight
different ad s's you have to flash off
all before you can get to sight it's
gotten so bad that the community now
jokingly refers to siege as a utility
removal simulator the first few minutes
of every round our attackers
methodically destroying equipment while
the last 30 seconds are saved for
frantic gunfights or somebody
desperately trying to plant the bomb
he's not got enough HP to make a
crossover from bolo that's a lot of
damage incurred there from just some
leaves and traps and he's gonna continue
to not check and incur even more damage
from for total lesion traps now okay 50
HP and the gas canisters are gonna chip
away the other thing wildly affecting
the meta are the nerfs buffs and changes
to operators kids a recent example is
the year 51.2 patch which swapped out
bucks grenades for claymores and
controversially up to Yang's flash
candelas from three to four while also
giving her smoke grenades these changes
suddenly made her incredibly powerful on
offense and her pick rate went through
the roof but again Ubisoft listened to
the backlash and actually reverted
Yang's kit after a week of community
complaints
it's a tough balancing dilemma because
the operators their kids and sieges she
reflects
ability are what make it so challenging
and ambitious as an eSport none of this
is to say that the C's developers are
thoughtlessly throwing content at us to
see what sticks it's actually quite the
opposite
we know that the developers are just as
passionate about siege as are the people
who play it it's one of the rare games
where the developers actually interact
with the community and often share their
thoughts and ideas about recent patches
and changes to the game we're back with
another Rainbow six siege developer this
time we are joined by Jean Baptiste he
is the lead game designer for Rainbow
six siege if there's a positive to be
taken from this whole situation it's the
fact that the siege community isn't
[ __ ] on the game because that's a
cool thing to do I get the overwhelming
sense that people are upset because the
game they love the thing they've spent
thousands of hours playing isn't in a
good place and they desperately want it
to be and it's a little strange talking
about siege this way when I truly think
it deserves to sit alongside other tier
1 eSports like csgo or League of Legends
I mean as a January 1st this year siege
had 55 million registered users and the
2020 invitational was ridiculously good
now should be the best time to be a
siege fan but it's not my cameras have
never been a problem in the past